a young child it became confirmed in my
mind that being Muslim meant that I was
a terrorist it was a source of ridicule
and I would really want to deviate away
from those people and act extra white
next to my friends I abandoned my race
My Religion my faith my God to the point
now that I'm literally reading the Quran
my mom used to make me read that when I
was a child you know I never really
wanted to I always like struggled or
whatever and now I've actively started
reading it by my own accord
have you heard of the savima Norway
Masjid project your brothers and sisters
are Islam yet are establishing a one of
his kind Masjid Tower and Community
Center in the capital of Norway and they
need our urgent support now click the
button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video
foreign
brothers and sisters and dear friends I
watched the video somebody sent me of a
brother called Hamza he's born as a
Muslim and he became atheist and in this
video he talks about his Reflections
about Andrew Tate and many other things
he's somebody who focuses on developing
oneself and becoming the better version
of yourself and that is amazing so
there's some key things that he touched
upon let's watch the video for ourselves
and come back as a young child it became
confirmed in my mind that being Brown
was a bad thing being Muslim meant that
I was a terrorist it was a source of
ridicule and bullying in school till
eventually I started adopting more of
this like white British culture but I
never really fit in with the people here
but I also just see like this young boy
who was so pressured by the society and
the media around him that convinced him
that being Brown was a bad thing that
being religious was a bad thing that
being Muslim meant that you're a
terrorist and that's all I saw every
single day on the TV every single day
here in the news and everything that
okay brown people are bad and you know
Muslims are terrorists and so of course
I didn't want to identify with that when
there would be like some kind of
terrorist attack I would literally
personally feel shame and I would rarely
want to deviate away from those people
and act extra white next to my friends I
abandoned my race My Religion my faith
my God
so one of the things that he mentioned
was what that he hated being Brown he
had to be a Muslim and this is exactly
one of the issues as subhanallah drive
people away from Islam and the religion
why because of the inferiority complex
because sadly the like he said the news
outlets Etc you know Muslims will be
dehumanized Etc you wanted to associate
yourself with it and sadly sometimes
that is the case and with this case
subhanallah even though that was the
reason but you can see that even popular
influences like Andrew Tate and likes
what happens is that when you see such
people come to Islam Etc it also boosts
your confidence a bit and also to be a
bit more comfortable and look into you
know actually maybe I might have
mistaken so it just shows you how the
Dynamics in our society can have an
impact on your decision-making factors
and which is another thing that Hamza
mentions when it comes to Freedom do we
really choose party you need drinking
alcohol enjoying yourself I did all of
that you can literally see my journey
through these hundreds of videos that
I've made you can see that this is real
that I indulge in that lifestyle we have
hundreds of videos of me in parties
walking up with girls I enjoyed that
lifestyle all that the Godless West has
to offer and here I am today in front of
you saying it wasn't that great because
once you've fulfilled all of these
Primal desires of yours you're left with
this spiritual numbness this emptiness
and this is one of the things that led
me to Islam I lived a very similar
lifestyle to you hamsa partying girls
all that kind of stuff that you lived I
lived that lifestyle in and out partying
Club in different countries you name it
you know and you never brought me
happiness it never brought me happiness
you know as men like you said before the
opposite agendas because our biggest
weakness partying clubbing trying to be
cool going gym Etc I've done all of that
and to be honest till this day I you
know when it comes to personal
development training boxing uh jogging
all that kind of stuff I like to keep
myself fit so alhamdulillah we have a
lot of similarities between myself uh
and you you know I'm actually you're a
handsome guy I don't know you know I
don't know if I'm as handsome as
yourself mashallah but the thing this
year that hamdullah we have some
similarities one of the things that I
noticed before I came to Islam was what
that I realized that uh one philosopher
said this as well that man is Born Free
but in shackles everywhere this concept
that we think that we have a choice that
we choose yes we believe in Free Will
that God Almighty is given free will but
also but we also believe in Qatar that
God Almighty is predestined everything
there they work together how we don't
know but the point is this I'm not
talking about that our decision factors
are influenced by our society you're not
available
[Music]
in just as girls go in these high heels
and these dresses Etc they are free
reason why do they do it because they
look good in it the same way I would
have a specific jumper that would go to
a nightclub because I believe that look
good in it but I hated it so much it was
so uncomfortable why didn't I do it out
of choice or coercion it was absolutely
coercion because I believe that I
couldn't look good in it gave my haircut
every week you know it's expensive
because I look good that is the point
guys and that's exactly what Hamza is
talking about when it comes to choice
you do not have a choice these Society
Implement forces you to do things you
don't want to do and then you're told if
you're told how to think how could you
ever say you have a choice that is the
point now Hunter develops Hamza talks
about developing yourself your character
your income Etc now this is well and
good Hamza I want you to realize
something because you read the Quran I'm
really happy may Allah bless you and
keep you from inshallah as your brother
we're here for you um you know off
camera if you want anything get in
contact with me I'm at your service if
there's any questions you have you can
watch my debates and discussions I have
of Christians atheists maybe that can
help you as well is look at the effect
that we give to our appearance yeah our
body I know you're if you're
bodybuilding you're going to be what
bicep I mean what body you're training
yeah how long you need to train the
training how many sets you need to do
you don't do the same workout again
because it doesn't have the same effect
on the muscle growth yeah you need to
change it up a bit um the food that you
eat to the time you sleep yes everything
is calculated why just to keep the body
in shape and the very same body which is
going to decay in our grave what about
the soul what is the food for the soul
the food for the soul is no other than
but the remembrance of Allah that's what
Allah says in the Quran only in my
remembrance do hearts find peace and
another verse Allah says if you forget
my remnants you'll have a depressed life
that's why no woman cause money none of
them did it for you just the way it
didn't do it for me because there comes
a point you become desensitized the
girls you become the sensitive like and
this is something to be I'm ashamed of
it's not something I'm trying to mention
like I'm proud of it just shows you guys
that as non-muslims when we live this
lifestyle while lie it will never bring
you happiness and the point is this
you will only find true happiness and
the sweetness of faith when you turn to
Allah and the effort that we give to our
body and the effort we give to prove
people to prove stuff to people whatever
it may be from the lifestyle that will
live into the stuff that we drive
whatever may be if only we focus that
energy to the one who created us if we
give all that effort to our bodies and
the people that we want to help whatever
it may be yeah or prove to what about
the one who created us and perfected us
and sustains us till this very day even
when you use an 80s you're coming and
Allah asks Allah inshallah you come to
Islam even in this journey bro Allah
carried on providing for you Allah
carried on looking after you this is how
merciful Allah is he is the most
merciful and very merciful and he wants
nothing but gender for you and that's
what Allah says in the Quran is
indeed in the creation of the heavens
and earth and in the alternation of the
night and day there are signs for those
who have intellect those who Pond and
think hold on a second this cannot come
from nothing all this cannot be from
nothing it has to be from somewhere and
that's what I can see you knew this
Awakening you know we can see that you
are waking up to this reality and Allah
says in the Quran in Surah is it that
they are created by none or are they
themselves the creators or have they
created the heavens and the Earth no but
they are sure of nothing and every time
I have a debate with atheists they end
up saying I don't know I don't know we
just don't know every single time watch
my debate and the Very powerful verse
which I'm going to end in Surah al-anam
Allah says and this is so so powerful
lady
[Music]
says
all Praises belongs to Allah who created
the heavens and the Earth and made
Darkness and Light yet those who
disbelieve equate others with their lord
he is the one who created you from clay
and destined the term the fixed term
lies with him yet you are in doubt he is
the true God in the heavens and the
Earth he knows what you conceal and what
you reveal and he knows what you earn
yet whenever aside from the sign of the
Lord comes to them they do nothing but
turn away from it so they rejected the
truth when it came to them now they
shall come to them a full account of
what they use to ridicule you are always
worshiping something if you're an
atheist which I am so I'm not being
hateful or anything I am too but if
you're an atheist and you don't believe
in God you're still worshiping something
you still have some kind of God okay
it's not a religious God it's not the
god from the Bible it's not Allah but
you still worship something you know I
carry this content I hope this makes
sense I carry this concept in my mind
okay you're always worshiping something
religious people worship a God in the
holy book atheists what do they worship
my brother Hamza like you said before
atheists also believe in God all they do
is just give God's attributes and credit
to Mother Nature Evolution Randomness
big bang these are the things that
created us this is the greatest
oppression against God the one imagine
you caters and provides for us and looks
after us and gives us everything in
what's paradise for us we turn around
our back to him and we insult him and we
give what is due to him to others and
that's why you speak the atheists they
give that credit to all of these
entities yes these these things which
none of them deserve to be God and never
can be God the point another I'm
literally reading the Quran my mom used
to make me read that when I was a child
and then I never really wanted to I
always like struggled or whatever and
now I've actively started reading it by
my own accord and I called my mom two
days ago and told her and I just saw the
biggest smile on her face when I told
her that I started reading you know our
holy book she just got like so happy she
told me it was the right thing she told
you and myself that this path that
you've started by reading the Quran
indeed the Quran is a light indeed the
Quran is a guidance you've started in
the most beautiful place actually please
please make Dua before I came to Islam
made the story make Dua say Allah if you
are there please guide me this is the
truth show me signs and guide me till
next time Brown sisters send this
guide him and if you need any
information if you want to get in
contact I'm pretty sure you can go eat
something inshallah if you're in London
or wherever till next time
have you heard of the savima Norway
Masjid project your brothers and sisters
are Islam Nets are establishing a one of
his kind Masjid Tower and Community
Center in the capital of Norway and they
need our urgent support now click the
button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video